ah
[Música]
sí
hola mi nombre es manuel e izaguirre soy
comunicador de profesión y cineasta de
vocación promuevo el cine en mi región
en lambayeque del norte del perú y estoy
muy feliz de estar con ustedes en esta
charla télex para saber tú que
bienvenidos mi primer recuerdo y
acercamiento al cine
fue en el año
1999 siempre faltaba clases
universitarias a clases de filosofía de
teología y me iba al cine fórum y era
asesor de cortometrajes en el curso de
mi gran maestro alejandro machacuay
lo que para muchas personas pudo haber
sido una suma de malas decisiones no
faltar a clases jalar el dinero
invertido en la educación ahora lo miro
hacia atrás lo miro en retrospectiva
y puedo decir que fueron las mejores
decisiones que tome en mi vida
decisiones que para muchos podrían ser
malas esta cuota de sacrificio es como
la gran metáfora de querer sembrar el
gusto por el cine en una pequeña e
informal ciudad al norte del perú y eso
es chiclayo por más duro que parezca que
suene es un lugar con instituciones que
le dan la espalda a las prácticas
artísticas o que lo hacen durante un
corto tiempo para luego abandonarlo no
todas pero una gran mayoría así
recuerdo el año 2004 cuando junto a mi
gran amigo milton caló piña ambos
grandes amantes del cine decidimos crear
el primer taller de cine en la región
lambayeque
experiencia que duró dos años ya que hay
un consejo fundamental para quienes
deseen promover un arte en cualquier
región del perú hay que hacerlo por
pasión y rompiendo algunas normas
recuerdo que sin tener el permiso de la
universidad pedíamos un aula y dictaba
más historia del cine realización
cinematográfica prácticamente escondidas
nadie lo sabía ninguna autoridad y lo
hacíamos estudiantes de comunicación
contabilidad derecho arquitectura de
diferentes universidades la experiencia
la iniciativa de instaurar un taller sin
experiencia previa era compartir lo poco
que sabíamos en ese entonces de cine
pero sobre todo hacerlo gratis sin
importar el tema económico
estábamos movidos por la cinefilia por
la pasión y sobre todo aprendiendo de la
mirada de jóvenes interesados en la
cinematografía chicos de la región
novedosas queriendo producir esta
dinámica es fundamental para instaurar
el aprendizaje de un arte que nazca de
adentro de la iniciativa personal y no
de las instituciones hay que evitar esa
espera absurda y tonta de las
aprobaciones oficiales
esa burocracia horrible que acompaña a
una universidad un colegio hay que
arrojarse a la piscina tomar riesgos
tener como lema mejor pedir perdón que
pedir permiso no hay de otra
si no lo haces tú nadie mucho menos un
centro de estudios vendrá a pedirte lo o
lo va a incluir en sus planes de estudio
o un colegio o un instituto
tienes que hacer que eso sea obligatorio
que sea necesario en un centro de
formación
con el paso de los años más escuelas de
comunicación aparecieron en la región
empezaron a funcionar se hicieron más
conocidas pude participar en la creación
de uno de esos planes de estudio allá
por el año 2005 nuevamente sembramos la
importancia de enseñar zinc en los
primeros ciclos
incluimos la enseñanza de historia y
realización cinematográfica en ese silao
fue aceptado fue como ganar una primera
gran batalla pero en silencio el cine
tenía su lugar en aquel plan de estudios
si deseas promover el cine desde el
espacio en el que te encuentres en
cualquier lugar en cualquier entorno
incluso mucho más en el académico no
sólo en señaló también profesa lo hazlo
en la práctica siempre mencionado la
necesidad que los profesores del
lenguaje cinematográfico o de
audiovisuales acompañen en los rodajes a
sus estudiantes que vayan con ellos a
grabar que se ensucien que pise en
tierra enseñar en la cancha en el set en
la locación por más que las autoridades
lo vean mal por más que te digan que no
se te van a pagar horas extra es la
mejor forma de enseñarlo nuevamente la
cuota de sacrificio la conexión que
logra el alumno y el profesor en esas
grabaciones es única y es algo que no se
va olvidar se gana el respeto la amistad
se rompe esa absurda verticalidad en la
enseñanza de los audiovisuales esos
audiovisuales que se enseñan sólo en la
teoría en el papel eso es mentira tiene
que enseñarse en la práctica
como aquellas ocasiones donde
desaprobado cursos en la universidad era
lo mismo
dejaba de ir a clases me iba con amigos
grababa cortos
seguía desaprobando pero valen la pena
tomaba riesgos y hay que hacerlo cuando
uno quiere enseñar un arte en una región
como la nuestra
llega la etapa en la vida de todo
cinéfilo o cineasta amateur donde debe
comer y decidir me dedico a hacer plata
o me mantengo firme en mi vocación parte
instaurar el ideal de hacer cine en una
ciudad tan compleja y descuidada
culturalmente como chiclayo es saber que
no tiene un trabajo para poder subsistir
debes comer debes pagar las cuentas la
luz el agua el internet tu celular pero
debes sostener en paralelo eso que te
mueve a seguir así no tengas un billete
en el bolsillo de eso se trata la pasión
debes mantener el ejercicio profesional
de grabar uno o dos cortometrajes al año
no te quedes si estás como profesor o
estás haciendo una chamba que no te
gusta dedicarle un tiempo a hacer una
película
yo he practicado el oficio con amigos
con los equipos que podían prestarme o
alquilar cualquier equipo el que sea me
acuerdo de aquellos primeros cortos
hechos los fines de semana sin guión sin
plan de rodaje pero con una energía y un
entusiasmo que hasta ahora recuerdo y me
emocionan
y que creo que motivaban a muchos en ese
entonces de pronto esos trabajos
pequeños sin presupuesto ni
planificación sin nada de organización
empezaron a cobrar valor cuando me
percaté que era una terapia para mí que
era una especie de catarsis y encontraba
respuestas a mi vida personal el cine
como una forma de entender te retrata en
un documental a mi abuela mi padre a mi
hijo a mi tía a mis amigos a mi hermana
a un colegio que me llamaba la atención
y a mí mismo estas películas encontraron
un público sin pensarlo no contagiaron a
muchas personas y si deseas que esto
suceda en el entorno donde vives donde
estés pues tienes que hacerlo quizá
escuches esta charla en un celular es
más la segunda cámara que me está
grabando es un celular
y después debes encontrar un par de
locos la gente que crea en tu sueño que
cree en tu mirada y que te acompañen y
que te ayuden a hacer películas sin
dudarlo sin miedo y aquí se repite un
patrón nuevamente romper las normas para
hacer que un arte prospere y se
ramifique en los hombres y mujeres de un
espacio poco acostumbrado al arte sobre
todo en las regiones del perú
puede sonar contradictorio
pero ante un escenario adverso y seguir
una pasión es necesario retarte con
proyectos que parezcan imposibles el
resultado lo comprobarás luego lo
importante es no quedarse con la tarea
pendiente de concretar aquello que te
mueve cuando me dedique a ser docente
algo que nunca quise hacer decidí que
mis alumnos hicieron una película en el
centro penitenciario de la región donde
vivo en la cárcel fue un caos completo
obtener el permiso a los papás la
universidad se volvió loca pero se logró
el documental se terminó grabando semana
y media en el pabellón de varones y
mujeres del penal de chiclayo
esos chicos cambiaron su forma de ver el
mundo entendieron a las personas y al
cine como una forma de cambiar la
sociedad se arriesgaron a formar parte
de una obra cinematográfica que luego se
difundió en todas las prisiones del perú
romper lo establecido las normas y el
contracorriente tomar riesgos la única
manera de hacer películas en un lugar
negado la cultura cinematográfica como
resultado de todo esto fue un proyecto
maravilloso el primer largometraje
universitario del perú un salón dividido
en tres grupos haciendo mediometrajes
cine guerrilla desde las aulas desde las
aulas universitarias pero también podría
ser desde el colegio sin equipos
profesionales con equipos de sonido
caseros solo con las ganas con el ímpetu
de contar la historia de personajes
entrañables y urbanos
hay que entender a un salón de clase ya
no como un lugar simplemente para pasar
el curso sino como una incubadora de
proyectos
un salón de clase debe generar películas
y no solamente ser un espacio para subir
notas y muchas veces es el sí lago el
que nos obliga a eso y hay que ir
encontrar el cielo ese papel que lo
aguanta todo aburrido un papel que
muchas veces está ahí para cumplir
y mi última etapa trabajando en la
universidad estuvo plagada de las peores
decisiones de mi vida las peores
tanto personales familiares económicas
las peores fue un espacio de crisis con
desencuentros
pero allí encontré a mi gran amigo
carlos guerrero y juntos decidimos sacar
adelante un laboratorio de cine gratuito
en la universidad casi marginal sin esos
benditos permisos que pueden demorar
seis meses en una universidad fue un año
maravilloso de aprendizaje de
experimentación fue como regresar al
origen de esta charla en ese primer
taller gratuito movido únicamente por la
pasión
los laboratorios son espacios de
experimentación y de aprendizaje
colectivo y colaborativo deben formar
parte de cualquier lugar donde se quiera
forjar una cinematografía mucho más
fuera de las capitales en las regiones
esos lugares siempre olvidados por el
centralismo tan marcado en los países
sudamericanos un laboratorio desarrolla
el potencial de quienes lo integran y
permite romper los códigos o estructuras
establecidas ir contra el canon contra
las normas
terminar un laboratorio con películas
cortas hechas y exhibidas compartidas
reflexionadas dialogadas en espacios
presenciales o digitales
reitero algo importante
sin esas malas decisiones ese
laboratorio no hubiera existido
cuando deje de ser profesor estando
fuera de la universidad
junto un grupo de amigos decidimos
impulsar un emprendimiento de formación
cinematográfica producción y exhibición
no teníamos un centavo estábamos vicios
nada
eso del capital para iniciar un negocio
era un flor o no teníamos plata
eran palabras sin sentido pero nos
atrevimos hoy tenemos más de 30 eventos
entre talleres clases maestras y cursos
también más de 40 cortometrajes en un
catálogo propio incluso dos
largometrajes por producir y un proyecto
educativo para enseñar cine en las
escuelas del norte peruano en la
macrorregión norte para estudiantes de
cuarto y quinto de secundaria y también
para los profesores si no eres feliz en
el lugar donde estás si perdiste el
trabajo pues empiezas de cero y es muy
seguro que encuentres un espacio de
libertad para hacer las películas que
quieras sin ideologías que manchen o
detengan ese arte o sin barreras
impuestas por quienes jamás entenderán
la importancia enseñar un arte como el
cinematográfico mucho más en un espacio
como el nuestro
sostener un lugar que forme y produzca
es muy difícil en cualquier parte del
mundo pero es fundamental para reforzar
y satisfacer a esos jóvenes que quieren
y sueñan con hacer películas
quizás hayan algunos votos de pobreza es
verdad puede que pases muchos meses en
dinero trabajará sin beneficios sociales
también serás un freelance que puede
tener carga de desempleado y es algo que
sucede mucho en nuestro país pero ahí en
esos peores circunstancias donde tienes
menos dinero pero una felicidad absoluta
de ver películas estás hechas por tus
alumnos por ti proyectadas y reconocidas
donde el público también se reconozca es
donde te das cuenta que romper las
normas para enseñar y hacer cine en tu
región valió absoluta y completamente la
pena y fíjense el dinero llega llega en
función al trabajo a la organización a
cómo te empiezas a planificar a cómo
asumas el futuro de ese cine que estás
enseñando hoy miro hacia atrás y también
observó el presente de la región
lambayeque el cineclub de lambayeque y
el festival internacional cortos de
vista tienen casi 15 años de labor
ininterrumpida algo casi heroico en
nuestro país muy extraño incluso en
muchos otros lugares del mundo
también hay muchos cineastas regionales
que quieren contar historias
maravillosas hay muchas películas que
quieren estrenarse y que se han detenido
por la pandemia pero debo reconocer que
aún no somos nada mejor dicho aún la
ciudad o quienes la dirigen no intentan
entender lo que significa hacer cine
arte o cualquier otra expresión que
involucra la cultura
sin embargo eso no quita la valentía de
tomar riesgos que son asumidos por
muchos entusiastas del cine la vallecano
personas fuera de las instituciones
gente como yo que nunca se detuvieron y
siguieron firmes por hacer que el arte
no sea aplastado por un sistema
institucional o rible engorroso o por
quienes piensan que el arte es una
pérdida de tiempo sigamos haciendo cine
nos vemos
[Música]